c'est cyril féraud à votre ami cyril
féraud est entouré de pom pom girls des
maisons de retraite
est-ce que cyril féraud et déguisés en
reine des neiges qui fait le ménage ou
est-ce que cyril féraud vient site une
proposition mystère pom pom girls voilà
pourquoi je le vois bien des légendes
il est avec nous ce soir
cyril féraud
[Applaudissements]
et aujourd'hui c'est un doublé
exceptionnel puisque cyril féraud et
avec elle je les ai jamais caché il fait
partie de mon top 3 de mes animateurs
préférés pas ta famille mois si les
frères de l'autre et côtoie voilà c'est
ça il ya une grande fan de toi dans le
public à la nage et odette voilà odette
et on l'a même vu un petit micro dette
parce qu'on voit la sienne
personnellement il est très très chaud
le faire on a changé à la changer
alors ce qu'un animateur télé vous
l'aimez bien aimé ce prix gérard si vous
trouvez vêtu l'égard du régime
je vois slam dr il s'appelle cyril
féraud quand on pense à cyril féraud si
c'est cyril féraud et bien vous
participerez haslam il fera encore
monsieur jospin voilà ce monsieur
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
il a plu
oui croire des seuils
[Applaudissements]
vous remettez vous vous installez c'est
vrai vrai est ce que vous vous êtes fan
de séries depuis combien de temps depuis
ses débuts pratiquement away est
pratiquement et j'ai tout de suite vu
que ce serait le l'animateur vedette
très vite
ah ouais et la télé et vous vous et vous
aimez beaucoup
pourquoi cyril en fait c'est quoi c'est
physiquement il vous plaît ça oui bien
sûr avait déjà c'est votre sim avec we
créant du il est drôle
ouais il a une nature elle est super à
l'aise même quand il était tout jeune
déjà s'asseoir en face et à merde
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
faut venir voir l'émission